[Music]
hey everybody what's going on yeah i've
been looking forward to doing a show on
this yeah we talked about it a little
bit on friday night but i was kind of
like well
you know keep some of it back because we
want to do like a whole show about it
yeah everybody it looks like everybody's
still kind of
drifting drifting in
got some people coming
but um
yeah northman
had people on the show asked me you know
hey uh you know what'd you think of that
how good was it
this movie is [ __ ] bad ass
yes
bad ass
that's what it is this movie okay y'all
know that one of my favorite movies of
all times is conan one all right i i've
watched that movie millions of times
[ __ ] picked it apart
listen to it with [ __ ] john
millions's [ __ ] uh uh commentary
um compared it with again you know
nietzsche and philosophy if you want to
call it philosophy but um
looking conan one's a masterpiece a lot
of people have never seen it they don't
have any idea what i'm talking about you
see that [ __ ]
on
you see conan on it and
a really good copy of it on blu-ray on a
really good television with headphones
or something with the [ __ ] music
jacked up because it's basically you're
seeing an opera and everything that
happens in there makes sense
um
if you understand philosophy all right
now some of it didn't make sense turns
out there's some [ __ ] deleted seeds
all right and it makes a lot more sense
with some of the deleted scenes
reinstalled and they did install
the stuff that had gotten deleted in
some copies
my copy is still missing one of the
scenes where conan starts talking to a
super tight about spring and then it
started to make all the [ __ ] sense
with the eye of the serpent the necklace
that he gave to valerian when she gave
it back and he starts talking about for
all these years we've got we've been
fighting and got nothing in return and
spring comes you know all this kind of
[ __ ] you know we need to [ __ ] stop
this life basically what he's talking
about um talking about the sacred
feminine there's a lot of [ __ ] in there
and it wasn't that that that scene is
not in my copy
but they restored the original ending
where the princess takes him back
so uh okay people people are starting to
come in now all right
so uh but yeah i know conan
well
all right
i've just analyzed it over and over
again so i'm not approaching the
northmen with a superficial knowledge
okay of conan i [ __ ] i'm approaching
northmen with the experts understanding
of conan
and this movie stands right along with
it
it's it's good it's real good i've only
seen it once there's a lot of stuff i i
didn't quite pick up
but it homages conan over and over again
without copying it it's just they've
seen conan and they want you to know
that yeah we've seen conan okay a lot of
things happen in the same order from
conan
but this is
only kind of a
a retelling more like an homage
uh it has a lot of spirituality in it
but it's all everything is norse style
norse and [ __ ] um
uh the tone is very different from conan
it's uh
uh with folk horror like like mid-summer
or
again you know uh what's the other one
[ __ ] wicker man or mixed in with
[ __ ] uh heredity hereditary
hereditary yeah
it's it it's it's action adventure
it's a conan style story
but it's [ __ ] hardcore man
it the tone is
almost satanic
but still
ruthless but still [ __ ] kind of
beautiful there's something beautiful
about it you know
it's just a real good story
here's a here's a good example
conan is more like iron maiden all right
this is more like cradle of filth or
[ __ ] celtic frost or slayer like that
that's the difference in tone
but it's still real good you know
i just i want to see it a couple more
times it doesn't have the same kind of
symbolism in it
um
but it doesn't have to it's a different
movie
what do you think jen well the thing
about it is that yes it does homage uh
conan and actually robert eggers did say
that he took some inspiration from conan
but the story of this is actually based
on a very old norse saga
uh the legend of amleth
which was actually the inspiration for
shakespeare's hamlet okay which a lot of
people have said because people have
said oh it's an updating of hamlet
they're like not really because hamlet
was based on this older
norse story yeah um so that's why this
has uh this is also kind of like hamlet
it's a great movie this is this is like
a norse version of apocalypto the movie
apocalypto it's it's like that um it's
as great as that although i'm gonna give
this this i say is better than
apocalypto even though apocalypse does
great
[ __ ] happens in the damn norse spirit
world it happens in his imagination the
way he sees it he sees a tree of life
he's seeing his ancestry at certain
times and you get to see what he's
seeing in his mind and it's [ __ ] it's
bizarre he's seeing the tree of life
with ancestors on it
that are dead and they're [ __ ]
corpses and then he sees like an unborn
coming ancestors that are alive but they
haven't been born yet that was [ __ ]
great
you see in valkyries ghosts
people have premonitions
um premonitions that kind of come true
um
it's just awesome
it's awesome's tail
it's legendary it it it's gonna stand
with conad conan one it'll it'll it'll
be remembered like that it's just
awesome i kind of i kind of feel like
this movie you know what's kind of
awesome is that robert eggers you know
his first movie being the witch and then
his second one being the lighthouse
which were uh you know lower budget but
they were kind of more indie films he
he got
a studio to give him like 70 million
dollars to make this one sadly i don't
think it's gonna make it back uh at
least in the theater it will
it's not there yet yeah but
i mean you have to admire the [ __ ]
balls of making a movie they don't
really make a lot of movies like this
because it's kind of like
you could say it's sort of like an epic
historical
you know saga and they do make movies
like that but
there's just something different about
this one that's i'm not sure like how
like how to describe it it's really
um
historically accurate like to the period
um you know everything i mean
everybody's speaking english obviously
but you know they're not speaking old
norse or anything which i got that kind
of surprises me but he was like maybe
that's just like a step too far
that would be like too much of a pain
because that seems like some [ __ ] he
would do but um everybody's speaking
english but other than that
it's
like completely historically act they
had all kind of like um you know
professionals like uh you know
historians from that uh area area for
that time period um consulting on it so
he could get everything as accurate as
possible
and so it has that sort of like grounded
in reality thing like all of the and
it's not like a big epic because i kind
of feel like don't they have that tv
series vikings which i've seen a few of
those that's pretty good but that seems
like mostly kind of just centered around
like the fighting
and this has fighting in it too but it's
not like a big epic like oh big epic
battles or anything like that when
there's violence it's usually kind of
like one-on-one or it's just kind of
like as it was a small group right so
it's a lot more realistic it doesn't
have
but it has an epic scope but it's more
realistic but then on the other side of
it it also has much like the lighthouse
had it has
dreamlike imagery because at some points
like the characters kind of go on you
know it's like a spirit walk type of
thing or you know there's there's kind
of like an occult
uh kind of thing to it going along with
their beliefs let me answer some
questions real quick okay uh yeah this
is a movie it's not a series okay
i think there's another series or movie
called
north men not north the north man the
north men but that's not the same one
we're talking about
and uh yeah it was talking about conan
the movie not the books that the the
john millius movie the first one
and there's about three different edits
that i know of of that movie and
i don't think they all have everything
in each edit
so
some edits are better than others
but uh yeah so that's what we're talking
about
it's a movie
that's great it's a great movie
it is i meant unborn descendants not
unborn ancestors but his ancestors were
dead somebody be killed
he sees them in the tree
and they're rotting and [ __ ] you know
some of them some of them have not yet
been born so i don't want to spoil the
movie if you guys haven't seen it it's
still in some theaters it needs to be
seen before it goes i'm definitely going
to buy a high quality version of this
[ __ ] it's going to on blu-ray it's
going to maybe 4k just depends on how i
feel so i can help i'm going to put it
right next to
milius's conan
and now you know some people well that's
not the real code
i just judge me i just judged the conan
movie based upon john millius and and
and um oliver stone's original vision
for what it was
you know what i mean and it's a
self-contained movie it mostly has to do
with friedrich nietzsche and it's it
quotes nietzsche as the movie starts so
it's just it's just another rendition of
conan
if you like that movie you will love
this movie
and i kind of feel like i've been
watching other people's kind of uh
breakdowns of it and almost everybody
that i've seen especially all the all
the male uh reviewers
[ __ ] love this movie yeah it's
extremely violent and ruthless very
cold-blooded very accurate to what we
know
of uh of
about what was written about um
vikings and and just the norse people
and berserkers they're in it uh the the
rooster in it um it's it's pretty
accurate uh the only thing that it
doesn't really go into
is that um your average your average
norse wasn't wasn't a viking a viking
was like a pirate or a raider they had a
very short growing season they had to go
out and steal
and raid and get
get [ __ ] gold and slaves for trade
and
so you know they ended up building an
empire and there's
they they were never conquered really
you know they never really lost they
were conquered by success they just
married so many
european women of christian
heritage that they just kind of bred
themselves out of existence their their
kids didn't want to be pirates
for you know what i mean
which is that's shown in this movie
because uh
as i was looking at his
his descendants in the tree they were
dressed as what i i thought they were
dressed as christians weren't they
i thought maybe because they do go a
little bit into
um because a couple of the slaves that
get uh captured and brought up later
they kind of like make fun of them for
people
for being christian but yeah so
that could be because they show his
daughter and his son who have not yet to
been born and they're wearing
red cloaks and veils like the virgin
mary and she's got a a sword and a
sphere and it looked like it did kind of
look like christian everything about
christian imagery that his descendants
were going to be christian and she went
back to the land of the ruse
remember she didn't stay
yeah so that's how i interpreted it i
thought they she went to orkney did she
not yeah but it wasn't that part of
where she came from though
somewhere in the room somewhere where
the roof they kept calling her the slav
yeah well she was russia yeah you know
the northern parts of russia was all
kind of like viking-esque territory she
was but they weren't they were they were
a different religion yeah so they
uh the way i interpreted the ending is
that his descendants were to be
christians
interesting yeah now that you mention it
i'm like yeah that did seem like what
they were getting at yeah and then and
and that
his daughter is basically dressed like a
medieval virgin mary yeah remember she
had to clog the veil and everything so
that's how i interpreted it is that
the northmen because that's what
happened in in reality in in in history
that's what happened to the vikings well
so that would make sense like to put
that in there their their descendants
ended up being christians
scoop dog points out uh that bjork is in
this movie or slasher fred points out
yeah she's only in one scene she plays
like a um like a seer like a sorceress
type of character uh and she's actually
great like her the the costume and stuff
like that looks really really cool uh
but yeah and then uh scoop dog is
bringing up uh the sugar cubes which
yeah i was a big fan of as well i
actually bought uh life's too good on
cassette when it first came out and that
was like a really really back in 88 and
that was like a really really great uh
album cold sweat birthday those are
really great songs there are big fights
in it but they're not like
which i think it's great they didn't do
the
the the lord of the rings style [ __ ]
battle that's kind of what i used to get
yeah where it's just like these big huge
like that didn't exist in reality it's a
well this one is a lot more intimate
because you know it's only like a
handful of
people yeah
you got you have to realize that
a kingdom really was a glorified
plantation or you know what i mean it
was a farm
that's who the king was
you know and it was uh you know you were
lucky if it was a few hundred people you
know that was a pretty big kingdom you
know [ __ ] and then you might have you
might have 70 or 80 fighters
and they might wage war on another king
and it was a similar size thing and
that's what you see here you know they
start raiding the roosts and it's a
glorified plantation you know it's a
gang fight yeah it's just like a village
yeah essentially a village with a wall
around it yeah pretty much all it is
with maybe like 100 200 people in there
yeah
yeah it looked like more like about 60
or 70.
because remember they had the women up
in the gaggle that was only about 30 20
30 people yeah
you know and uh
when they rode in there the the [ __ ]
they don't you know the the vikings or
the the vikings that the the berserkers
were working for they only had one horse
remember
and the princess was on it that's right
yeah and she comes out and she says i
don't want any little ones i want big
ones and then they killed the children
yeah
she's like i just want the strong ones
yeah
most of them they just thought they were
yeah there's uh some some pretty like uh
hardcore [ __ ] in this like i said they
killed children in all kinds yeah they
just like put them in a thing and burn
them alive so like yeah well like i said
it's i i don't feel too bad like
spoiling it because like i said it's
it's not the exact same story as hamlet
but because hamlet was based on
this same myth that this movie is a
loose adaptation of it's not really i
mean it's just basically a straight-up
revenge story is what it is um you know
you have alexander sarsgaard at the
beginning who you know his character's
like uh amleth who's like a kid and he
sees his dad the king get killed by his
brother
and then he vows to
take vengeance and then you know then he
grows up and he kind of goes he has to
get like the right sword and he you know
goes to the you know like i said if
you've seen hamlet or if you've seen
conan it's pretty much the same like
kind of revenge
journey type sometimes
i need to go through my old vhs's and
see the original code and i don't see
that one because that one has the [ __ ]
up ending in it and it vhs looks like
[ __ ] compared to where it looked in the
theater
what you do is you want to go on amazon
prime and rent it it's only a couple
bucks rent it and see it on your damn hd
television
and it has the
the one that i saw on
the one that i saw on um
because i saw it on on amazon prime
before i bought my copy of it
it had the original ending restored
where the princess takes him back to
tulsa doom's place and she's with him
when he kills dulce doom and he almost
takes over the cult but he decides
against it you know and he goes through
the whole thinking thinker phase like
[ __ ]
um you know something out of a nietzsche
um
but it
and
when i bought my copy it was that same
version of it
but there's another version out there
you can see you can see somebody had
lifted the scene out
of where subitalian
and conan talk about springtime coming
and that happened right after
valeria died and he put her
the the eye of the serpent necklace on
and then he started talking about it's
not too late for us so you know he's
talking about that we could have
children as we're talking about we
should get married and have children
he's like nah that's not for us that's
it
that's that's a subatomic which like i
said this is kind of like a similar type
of thing because kind of the whole theme
of the northmen is
you know this kid i mean he was just a
kid when his uh father was killed and he
swore vengeance and that was like his
destiny that was his fate yeah and you
know as the story goes on and he has
other possibilities that are presented
to him he doesn't take um yeah it's kind
of like he has a choice
whether you know you can leave all this
behind and leave hatred behind yeah or
keep on going with that because that's
what your destiny is a lot of things
happen kind of in the same order as it
happened in conan uh
he loses everything
he doesn't really
he escapes and and has to survive on his
own
he doesn't become a slave
and fight in a pit instead he joins a
warrior cult of berserkers and becomes a
berserker
and uh then and then they go out and
raid for other people kind of like
mercenaries
and
this involves
doing the worst of the worst so you know
it's kind of like
killing children and women and blah blah
and that's kind of like a good analogy
but conan he did not care anymore life
death the same that's that's what they
were talking about and there was a
deleted scene that they took out of the
movie
they show conan killing all these people
and biting them and [ __ ] in the pit and
he's holding up his swords you know
doing all this and the crowds [ __ ]
loving it what they cut out is that
there was a scene where he fought two
twin females
and female gladiators killed them both
and was holding their heads up like that
and that was supposed to really shock
the 70s audience that this dude would
kill women
you know
and
i think i think the footage might still
be out there but it's not on any other
it's not on any version that i know of
but milius talked about it in the uh
in the commentary
okay that he wanted the the one where he
was holding up the two
female women's heads by their
hair and it was supposed to really kind
of like horrify
the audience of the very early 80s or it
was late 80s or early 80s it was 81 when
it
80 1980 or 91 i saw it in the theater as
a kid yeah that was the horrifying
people that because they didn't see that
on screen back then
where you have a guy who's supposed to
be the hero but he had murdered or
killed women right you know so emilious
wanted to push the boundaries of what
you would consider to be
a hero he had to [ __ ] be a total
savage in the beginning and then come
out of it
and that's that kind of happens in this
and this he's a berserker but he kind of
comes out of it but not really you're
still dealing with the damn
you're still dealing with the damn
viking man they were psychos i mean they
were [ __ ] psychos well and what he
does yeah he goes and he's with the
berserkers for a while but then he
figures he finds out where his foe is
his uncle uh
and he so he poses as a slave right like
allows himself to get he climbs on the
boat like and allows himself to get
enslaved so he can go to that dude's
farm
and uh [ __ ] with him right and he's done
a lot of bad [ __ ]
but he's going after people that are
even more evil than he is so it's all
just kind of uh
the movie kind of says well evil is a
spectrum you know yeah i mean even
they're even worse than him he does
horrible things yeah um but he's a
viking though yeah but you're he's still
like you still kind of want to i don't
want him to win you want him to win i
mean he still has some he still has
redeeming qualities particularly like in
his relationship with olga who is
another slave girl that he meets the us
she's slavic yeah once you realize how
evil the enemy is he starts doing [ __ ]
like freeing
freeing [ __ ] women that were bound up
getting ready to be sacrificed i it
doesn't say that he questioned odin it's
just that
the evil people he was after were better
sacrifices than these
slaves yeah and you know that's that was
that was how
he resolved the issue
and then in the end
once he overthrows this basically an
evil kingdom which like i said is a
glorified plantation
and this particular one doesn't have a
wall around it because it's in it's in
the northland
uh it's in iceland yeah
[Music]
he uh
basically says basically tells all the
slaves i'm your master now burn this
[ __ ] down you're free
yeah you know
and he he was their master he [ __ ]
killed everybody else
yeah you know he had he had the
authority to do it
you know it's a great movie it's great
and as i want to see it again there's a
bunch of [ __ ] that i missed but go ahead
yeah i mean i think that this is
probably if you're into viking [ __ ] um
this is probably the most period
accurate yeah viking thing that you're
ever going to see a religion and
everything they really took pains and
i'm going to say too that
i love the score of this
they used like a lot of really old like
that creepy like chanting and drums and
all that kind of stuff it was like
really really cool i loved willem dafoe
in this uh even though he's only in it
for like a minute um he's in at the
beginning like as a jester and then
later he's in it like as a creepy
severed head um so that's like pretty
cool he's like the shaman i guess like
type situation where they're doing like
the spirit walk like uh you know amlath
and his dad like when ambulance is a kid
where they're go channeling the spirits
of the wolves and finding their destiny
and all this other kind of stuff um
everybody in this was great i mean
alexander sarsgaard uh skarsgard who um
i guess he's of swedish ancestry and he
had been wanting to do like a viking
film like forever like a really accurate
one and so finally he got the chance to
do it and he's like he's a big dude um i
looked at yeah he's six foot five
because i've noticed like in the film
because i've seen him in other stuff but
i guess it didn't stick out to me like
how tall he was but in this like he's
definitely like towering over like a
bunch of the other people and he really
he was pretty buff before but they like
really like yeah like beefed him out
because he's supposed to be just this
big like beast-like yeah and he is
character yeah he's everybody
he's great in this everybody's
physicality matches up with
the feats that they're doing in this
movie nothing is out of character you
don't have 90 pound girls in cheerleader
outfits wiping out for hordes of nazi
soldiers they have any of that [ __ ]
if somebody's [ __ ] fighting somebody
and it's and it's kind of like true to
norse culture they're taking their
clothes off and fighting naked and [ __ ]
which they did that when they were
really serious they just [ __ ] took
all their other hit the car on the way
home from the movie theater tom is like
fighting naked on a active volcano you
can't get any more machos
[Laughter]
and it didn't look fake it looked real
it really did i mean yeah it didn't look
like [ __ ]
it didn't look like [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] anakin skywalker and obi-wan
kenobi fighting in on far it didn't look
like that it looked like they were
[ __ ] on a real damn volcano and
with a black sky because of all the dabs
so they could barely see each other you
know you couldn't really see they're
just like oh yeah they were like i will
meet you at the gates of hell
that was what they called that's what
they called that volcano the gates of
hell that's where you went down into the
[ __ ] hell yeah so that's it made
perfect sense so okay so they went down
there
to kill each other it was such a badass
scene and here's another thing
like i said if this was heavy metal
conan one is iron maiden this is cradle
of filth all right it's still a good
metal band it's just a lot harder all
right a lot more violent and ruthless
but it still had a lot of depth man it
had real all-star cast and everything
acting was [ __ ] great
it's like uh
oh [ __ ] what was i gonna say about it
i don't know um
it was something about the quality of
the movie i was just saying that the
tone is different but oh i was gonna say
the music um it's
conan had
that good classical almost wagnerian
[ __ ] who did that music it was
[ __ ] great you can just listen to the
conan soundtrack it's just great
classical music
[ __ ] man he's a real famous yeah uh the
problem with that soundtrack is that
it's in mono they went through all that
[ __ ] problem to get a damn orchestra
and write all that [ __ ]
and they recorded it in mono it's not
even stereo but anyway
they had to be as epic as that
but they couldn't copy that
and that would cost a lot of money to do
today so what they did is they did
nothing but just savage drums and
chanting and it's very effective
yeah i was into that chanting i was into
that and just evil satanic chanting and
[ __ ] drums and [ __ ] and it's just
it's [ __ ] great and i'm kind of
feeling like the way that it's put
across in the movie it really did feel
like period accurate to me it really
does like immerse you yeah in this world
i really did feel like
hey this is like 895 a.d or whatever
here it was um you know and these are
all actual vikings i didn't get you
don't get the feeling that anyone is
like acting no most of them aren't even
wearing shoes
barefoot
running around in the mud she must have
been miserable
because they look cold as [ __ ] and
they're just running around they shot
some of it in ireland and uh ireland and
some have been in iceland so yeah i'm
sure it probably was cold you know they
got the pretty girls that you know and
[ __ ] running around here barefoot
yeah they look dirty it looks good i
mean that looks
exactly like you would think that they
would look
i mean the [ __ ] they're enslaved
and they're and i think even the rich
people if that's what you want to call
them even they don't i didn't think they
don't even think they had shoes a lot of
them
i think shoes were just something
that's some fancy fancy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah everybody just looked
filthy yeah
and
cold cold
or high because they were taking drugs a
lot yeah and during this dam
during these damn vision walks and
spirit walks underneath the [ __ ]
ground with [ __ ] dead dried up dead
body parts and stuff and talking to
[ __ ] dead ancestors and [ __ ]
i really like i liked that because i was
kind of expecting it to be more like
um
you know just like more like a straight
ahead like traditional i should have
known better i guess because it's robert
eggers but um i was expecting it to be
more like a traditional
viking epic kind of story which it is
but i didn't expect there to be like so
much mysticism yeah in it and i thought
that was like a really cool it's almost
like an aspect of it it's almost like
that movie mid-summer with that folk
horror it has a big folk horror
feel to it
because whatever whenever they did
something they'd have to [ __ ] take
drugs and [ __ ] sacrifice somebody or
kill somebody or we're going to stab
this woman to death you know to appease
the gods and
that's what i was saying almost kind of
like apocalypto because that was going
on an apocalypto you know [ __ ] trying
to capture
sacrifices and
that was accurate too mel gibson
did a good job on it they're doing it in
this movie but they're doing it
with that all that damn soundtrack going
and it's just uh it has a horror element
to it you're like [ __ ] because they
believed in some weird ass [ __ ] they did
yeah you know there's a lot of
dismemberment the body parts nailed up
on things as signs and
yeah it's real good yeah it's pretty
gruesome i mean yeah it is pretty
gruesome yeah uh my my favorite scene
was the with the guy with no nose yeah
one dude just wanted to get no nose
will you explain how i got cut off yeah
the uh the kid cut it off
okay because remember uh there was
something happening remember after they
killed the king and amleth as a kid was
trying to run away and that guy like
grabbed him and he went like and he cut
the dude's nose off and then like later
on he recognized oh there's that no nose
guy yeah and don't for one second think
children are safe not only do children
get killed in this
children try to kill people too yeah and
use weapons and it's
the way it was
you know a little kid's gonna fight for
their life if you try to kill a kid or
that or a kid will
fight to defend somebody else if they're
under attack and that's that's that
happens in this you know on several of
many occasions
and bad [ __ ] happens to children
yeah i mean one scene in particular yeah
it's like pretty bad it made sense under
the time though because you couldn't let
any chil you couldn't let the children
of your enemies survive they'd grow up
in a few years and they'd come back and
they'd come back and kick so you had to
just wipe out everybody
yeah and that's what they did right but
they were all kind of feral
especially
vikings and berserkers they were pharaoh
basically they were in warrior cults
and they show what they tried to do to
them you know they were take a bunch of
drugs make them suffer a lot physical
deprivation and try to get them to
become bestial to get them to unleash
animal totems in them to become fierce
and go into combat wearing animal skins
or nothing you know
they didn't have any fear and they were
you know
they were going berserk they're going
bizarre
you know what they called it
well yeah that's kind of like very near
the beginning of the movie with like
ethan hawk who plays the first king who
gets killed and amleth as a boy that's
the thing when you know when amleth is
however old he was he looked about 10 or
11 or something like that and he takes
him to the shaman and they're doing like
the [ __ ] spirit walk basically to
like release like you said his animal
totem he gets him to be like a dog you
know what i mean like or a wolf or
whatever yeah it is not made up because
roman soldiers roman soldiers during the
roman period had noticed that you know
frankish
people and other people like gauls and
stuff that they were fighting and they
were all kind of viking like
would go would take their clothes off
paint their body go into [ __ ]
um frenzies uh bloodlusts and they would
say that yeah you'd be fighting some
guys and they'd be fighting kind of like
individuals but they're fighting
attacking all at once
and then
just out of the blue one of them would
turn and [ __ ] attack and kill one of
their own kind
without it because they just would go
into a damn frenzy and they were on
drugs too yeah you know
so they may kill each other
it's like when a bunch of sharks get
just like feeding frenzy oh sorry carl
the romans uh wrote down they were
scared of them yeah oh so yeah i guess
you would be
they were big they had long longer
swords than romans uh and and uh there
was kind of a
man crush going on between the romans
and the germans they call them germans
or frankish people or you know franks or
whatever
but they were all kind of
kind of viking type people
um who'd come from somewhere near east
probably they'd just walk in the area
and just beat each other's asses and
they were cannibals a lot of times and
worship strange gods evidently some of
them were christians already that the
romans were dealing with but they were
still just the same
you know just because somebody was a
christian didn't mean that they were
civilized in that period
some of them were [ __ ] worse
true you know they're like oh well we
don't like you sir we're going to do to
you what happened to our lord if it was
good enough for jesus then it's good
enough for you
you know they did all [ __ ] like that you
know yeah they were germanic christians
the coming of music that's right was
done by uh basil pollodorus
that's right basil apologies man that's
a [ __ ] i really do like that score
you can work out to that music
[Laughter]
lifting weights to that but i really
yeah but i really do like this this
movie doesn't really have
it doesn't really have a good classical
score like that does like a cinematic
score
like that it's a very very tribal yeah
kind of so which is very very keeping in
with the theme which like i said very
realistic but it does have like a i
don't want to say magical realism but it
does have like kind of a cult
kind of thing to it because they're you
know like i said they're they're going
into these like altered states yeah and
they're seeing valkyries as they die and
[ __ ] and they're going to valhalla and
they're seeing the tree of life and
they're seeing [ __ ] the gates of hell
and they're seeing it and they're
showing it to you
what they're seeing and
you know it's kind of warping your
reality but i'd imagine you know in
those days if you were a viking your
reality was pretty [ __ ] warped you
know you probably had a hard time
discerning between what you imagined
what you saw but it's all right there
and can i just say i love um
anya taylor joy in this yeah she's uh
she was in the witch too so she's worked
with robert eggers before she looks very
much like a
like somebody who would
be in this type of movie she's like so
funny looking but also like super super
cute i always thought kayla higgins said
isn't amleth an anagram for hamlet yeah
i brought that up earlier that
shakespeare actually based hamlet
on
the the story that this is based on like
the old norse saga the legend of amleth
uh so that's why it's a similar
story but yeah so this is this story is
actually much older than hamlet yeah
they're mentioning dogs that they bred
to fight vikings yeah there's a lot of
dogs in this they have a lot of war dogs
and uh
special thing i think it may be a a b
wolf i think is one of the things that
they show it's cg it's like a wolf and a
fox and a an otter all kind of combined
he sees it on a couple of occasions and
somehow uses that magic to cause the war
dogs to [ __ ] turn on their masters
it's i gotta see it a couple times well
the remember bjork told them
yeah yeah the sorcerer has told him yeah
that um
she says something like follow the
vixen's tail yeah so that's why like
when he sees it out there and it looks
at him like significantly so she called
it a vixen yeah i think that's what she
called it okay which is
well a vixen that's what a female fox is
called right yeah but i might be like a
female of other species as well but his
last name i believe is bee wolf
uh amleth i think his last name is bee
wolf right i'm not really sure like the
king's name which is beowulf saint dick
yeah that sounded like that's what they
were saying like the king's name the guy
that ethan hawk plays yeah his name is
uh arvindel war raven okay yeah but i'm
not really sure
uh
what amlath's last name was if he had
one the norse had a lot of imagination
when it came to classifying animals just
most things were just called bee wolf or
big wolf it just means big wolf
and it's like that's a big wolf that's a
[ __ ]
it's an elephant but it's like whatever
bigger wolf yeah
because wolf just meant predator
yeah so uh they may have been talking
about bears
it's probably what a b what a big wolf
was a bear
okay close enough then you see a big
wolf and you go yeah that's a big wolf
too
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
in the south we have them critters they
can be little or
big and they could be human that's a
critter too
[Laughter]
so that
i think that's what
beowulf means greater i believe
they're probably talking about bear
maybe bear but i didn't know like what
that animal was supposed to be because
it kind of looked like i think it was a
bee wolf
yeah it kind of looked like like you
said it sorta looked like a dog but it
kind of looked like a baby bear but then
it kind of looked like water like an
otter and it kind of looked like a fox
i think it was a bee wolf i'm not sure
if that's like a real animal or not not
very well by no it was a norse imaginary
animal and i think it was a bee wolf i
guess that's how he knew that it's like
oh that's the animal that the sorcerer
is she called a vixen
i'm pretty sure that's what she said
right like because remember she gave him
that
uh she told him like his destiny yeah in
that tomb or whatever and
i'm pretty sure that's what she said
follow the vixen's tale yeah i think
that's what she said okay how amleth
gets his sword and he does get a magic
sword all right
the sword cannot be drawn during day you
just can't even get it out of the
[ __ ] scabbard
all right but when it's out at night it
just [ __ ] it's almost like a damn
lightsaber to cut right through a human
just cleanly all right it's a badass
sword and they don't make a big deal out
of it but they did make a big deal out
of how he got it and he got it from
another dead viking and the the the
scene i loved it is a [ __ ] homage
to how conan got his sword from the
aqualonian i think it was enacted
was he no he wasn't an aquilonian what
he was an atlantean general who is
[ __ ] dead up in his crypt
it's an homage to that but better you'll
understand it as soon as it comes down
to the ceiling just like [ __ ] conan
did and everything and you see it you go
oh that's the same dude conan [ __ ]
and you see it but it goes differently
it goes differently you'll like you'll
like
yeah because this movie like i said is
not iron maiden this is cradle of filth
so you see it but you go nope that's not
how it's going to go
yeah well you can't take this sword you
just can't take it
yeah that's too easy
so yeah he has to go through a whole lot
yes go do some [ __ ]
yeah but yeah as soon as it's funny
because as soon as i saw that scene i
was just like oh like conan is like yeah
that's exactly what he's talking about
but what like that is similar in
everything robert eggers wanted to
homage conan a lot of yeah it's like i
said even though this is essentially the
same story as hamlet because he's like
an old uh north but he still wanted to
homage conan in the original story when
when milius is telling the story the one
that that his homage and conan was on
the run being chased by wolves and he
had to [ __ ] couldn't even make a
living for himself because he had been
released from slavery and starting from
zero okay
and wolves are chasing him he runs up on
top of a mountain of rocks and falls
through
and meets a [ __ ]
a dead
atlantean general he was even buried in
there with all his women
okay that's how badass he was he had all
this [ __ ] high-tech armor [ __ ] from
another era
and he takes that [ __ ] sword and with
that sword he's able to [ __ ]
start a life for himself
you know what i mean he takes a sword
and [ __ ]
the general just kind of collapses like
he just gives like he's given
he's bequeathing his [ __ ] inheritance
to a new
version of himself that's what it meant
okay
later on you know in in in in miley's
version it's basically the story says we
we men like conan are created through a
secession of different fathers
his natural father which did was he was
imperfect other his slave master who was
imperfect the general who was imperfect
just even all the way down to thulso
doom was his father but they were all
imperfect you're all being created by
the guys that you know the ones that
came before you that's what that's what
that story is talking about and this
story kind of does that too with that
particular scene he's kind of taken up
the
the mantle of the one who came before
him and he was evil [ __ ] also
okay and that's what this was about you
know it's good it's i just got to see it
again so i can get all the mythology
down because there is
a mythological tale there and a lot of
symbolism
a lot of uh
but
but you got to watch it several times
where you can pick up on everything yeah
because this is it's a long movie it's
like two hours and 17 minutes it didn't
seem long to me though and there's
probably gonna be a director's cut
that's even longer how much you won't
bet uh yeah probably a man i imagine it
probably will be but yeah i mean
this
was pretty [ __ ] epic and like i said
i don't think it's gonna be in the
theaters that much longer unfortunately
because
it made some money but i don't think
it's gonna make its money back uh in
theaters which is kind of a shame it
made more than i thought it would
especially for a robert dagger's movie
because usually he makes kind of like
lower key [ __ ] but
i really if you want to see it like i
would recommend seeing in the theater
because it has it's only been here a
couple more days and well and because
it's like so it's such a big like epic
and like the cinematography is just so
amazing yeah that it's really not going
to be the same experience one of the
best movies i've seen in a theater in a
long time yes and it's the best one in
the in the [ __ ] sword genre for for
in decades
in decades
yeah because it's not it's like not
hollywoodized at all it's not glamorous
at all it's very very realistic yeah you
know and i think that that's what's cool
about it it's an updated
version of what you would do if you
wanted to make conan again
all right that's what it is you can't do
conan it's it's the title is [ __ ]
owned
and they would want to try to make a lot
of money on it and to make a lot of
money on it they'd have to [ __ ] make
it pg and they'd have to do a lot of
[ __ ] [ __ ] to try to make that for
a general audience and that didn't work
out last time
when they did it
um
you'll end up with something like out of
the marvel universe and it'll suck look
it's not hard enough so they started
from scratch they used a [ __ ] real
story like i said hamlet
and then they [ __ ] or amleth and they
[ __ ] redid it
that conan's conan fans would instantly
know what it is that they're dealing
with even though it's harder it's less
fantasy yeah it's not it's not like uh
like a classic like sword and sorcery
like fantasy type of thing it's a lot
more grounded in reality even though it
does have like occult or magical yeah
aspects it has a horror
tone
yeah it's not
like i said this [ __ ] is rated r
okay very r
yeah it's pretty like people get really
[ __ ] up in this right and the original
conan movie was rated r but the ones
that came after it [ __ ]
they weren't they're pg they sucked
well you know yeah
and it was amelia's that did them
scoop dog says it's getting excellent
ratings yeah it's got um pretty much
universal acclaim i think it's 90 90
something percent on rotten tomatoes um
i haven't really seen
that many negative reviews of it um
pretty much all the ones i've seen have
been overwhelmingly positive yeah and
amc here only had it playing in one
theater once a day yeah once a day so
it's it's rotate now yeah i mean
well the thing about it is that we went
on a thursday yeah and it was the same
thursday that the new doctor strange
movie started so that was probably
showing in several theaters because
everybody was there seeing that i wish i
would have been able to see this in in i
didn't know it was this good yeah i
would have liked to see it in toby
because it was playing in dolby at first
yeah but man i missed it yeah we just
saw it in the regular theater because it
was only one showing yeah and it was
like it's 6 30 or something you got to
see this before it goes go ahead and go
on your amc app or whatever and [ __ ]
see this [ __ ] before it's out because
you're going to be you're going to miss
out it's badass i really did it i really
liked it and honestly i i would really
like to see it again like i said i got
really like
immersed yeah you know what i mean it's
really good at like building the whole
world and yeah it's long but
to me it just it didn't seem all that
long and it's not that it's like you
know oh action a minute or anything like
that i mean but it moves along pretty
good it's not like these big epic battle
scenes or anything like that but
it just has like realistic like violence
and realistic action and you know it
just kind of goes on this his revenge
quest and that's all it is it's
basically just a revenge story um so
yeah it's it's definitely definitely
worth watching um you know one of the
best movies i've seen in a long time uh
in that genre so yeah if you like viking
stuff then yeah you should totally see
it yeah nicole kidman is in it too yeah
she plays uh
gudrun
she's the queen i guess and uh yeah
she's she does a good job she actually
um
i i wasn't sure like because i kind of
thought her role was going to be a
little bit more minor but then toward
the end there's kind of like a
something that happens that i was just
kind of like oh [ __ ] all right she's got
like a bigger fit part in it uh than
than i thought and like i said i'm
really into like anya taylor joy is
really good in this too when he meets
when he meets her she's like you know
the love interest or whatever but
she's also a slave but she's also kind
of like a sorceress so she does like all
this kind of
magic and [ __ ] as well so she has so
he's kind of like he has the the brawn
and the strength and everything and she
has like the cunning and the magic like
earth magic so they're kind of like
working together to like bring about the
revenge that they want to bring about so
yeah um definitely worth watching i
would you know please see it in the
theater uh i really wanted to make his
money back because i would really like
if more movies like this got made
um
you know because they don't really make
a lot of big budget movies like this
and i really wish that we could
encourage that
but uh yeah so
you have anything else you'd like to add
before we that's it i'm just saying get
in there before it fucker's gone
i'm gonna see it again um
on
amazon prime but i wish i would have
seen it um in dolby and adobe it would
have been cool yeah oh well yeah but you
want to see it you want to see the big
screen and when the [ __ ] was over the
[ __ ] crowd was [ __ ] quiet as [ __ ]
yeah and i was like damn i think
everybody liked it though yeah i think
it was just they were just like damn
i heard like some other people like that
were commenting because i was looking at
um
comments on some of the other reviews
and some people said that when they went
to the theater like after it was over
everyone was just like sat there quietly
holy [ __ ] yeah yeah
so it was like kind of like that
everybody just like felt like they got
beat up or something like that
didn't we say that always the first time
we saw mad max yeah it's like fury robe
the first time i saw that in the theater
i said i just feel like i got my ass
kicked yeah
it's kind of i couldn't take it all in i
want to go back i want to see it again
yeah yeah
all right so we're going to go make some
tacos yeah so you guys have a good rest
of your weekend and we'll be back
tomorrow
talking about an old classic an old
mario bava
sci-fi movie yeah playing into the
vampires we'll be talking about that
tomorrow
so
have a good rest of your sunday and
we'll see you guys tomorrow